mike is with us in Pennsylvania hey Mike
how are you hey guys thanks so much for
having me sure man what's up yeah I'll
be concise so just let me know if you
need any more details I'm I'm married
I've got four young kids it's always
been a goal of ours to relocate someday
we just completed baby step three so now
it feels like the right time
congratulations Michael Emma thank you
it was a long baby step - yes here's my
dilemma I love my job or am and we've
got deep roots in this area but I hate
the part of the country that we live in
and I always have well so when you guys
get off of your advice and whether we
should stay or go what are the routes
both of our families are here we've got
the four kids and in various stages of
school we own a house my wife's very
close with their family here she does
agree with me that there isn't the
greatest but it's she's more she's not
as eager as I am to pick up and go what
do you hate about the area well for one
the winters are brutal
they're extremely cold they're long the
summer it's beautiful here where I lived
in the summer but it's brief we get
maybe two months of nice weather and
there's not a lot of opportunities as
far as jobs and the amenities of a big
city I want to live outside of a big
city in a warm area and I do have a
great job but I would like the comfort
of knowing that if I didn't have this
job whether voluntary or involuntarily
that I would have more opportunities and
I just don't feel confident about that
in this area who's more excited to leave
you or her Oh me without a doubt yes
I've been I've been wanting this for my
whole life ever since I can remember
she's read you early you grew up there
yes I did mmm interesting so she comes
in today and says let's sell the house
what goes through your your your head
then oh I feel like that's the
validation that I needed because I'm
doubting myself right now see I'm afraid
that I'm the grass is always greener on
the other side guy but I want to get out
of here and then I'll be just as unhappy
when I get wherever I'm going I mean
deep down I don't feel that way but it's
something I am worried about
so the draw of the other area in your in
your dream scenario is
and economic prosperity sure and the
amenities of a big city sporting teams
restaurants you know stuff like that
where we live is very rural there's not
a lot going on so everything's a
20-minute drive from here let me like I
can just walk you through my situation
my wife and I lived in Texas every
single day of our life
up until a little over two years ago and
we have de fruits close friends all of
our family and we had a vision of a life
with trees we had vision of a life with
running water year-round and we had a
just a picture in our head of a family
working in a situation similar to what
you've outlined and what I can tell you
in our family
it has been magic we've gone home to
Texas several times we still visit our
family we still love our family it's
been extraordinary but the key here is
we did it together it was a plan that we
made together and we waited until we had
the right job opportunity go what do you
do I'm in supply chain what do you make
household incomes about 130 okay
share that I'm just wondering if if he
left and three years later it was
horrible how hard it'd be to just come
back you know I think that might be
something that might be a possibility
sometimes it helps to remember like when
you're buying a car we get it in our
head like we have to drive this car for
8,000 years or something and you can
sell the car two months later if you
don't like it it's just a stupid car and
so maybe this isn't as permanent and
all-or-nothing decision as it feels like
maybe it is I don't know but I mean if
you moved and two years later three
years later you absolutely hated it it
wasn't what you thought everybody's
miserable including you and you might
even go back to your old employer they
maced you know hire you back I mean I
don't know but but you could you could
probably put the life that you have
there back together it
if you needed to or some semblance of it
right I I think that's great advice how
old are your kids Mike my oldest is 11
my youngest is 2 so I'm gonna give you
unpopular advice this is cool you called
this show so I'll give it to you
absolutely probably they don't get a
vote and they're gonna have a 10-year
11-year 4-year old picture of what the
world is and they're not gonna have the
wisdom and so everything is going to be
about but my streets gonna look
different and I'm gonna miss Timmy and
Susie and I know a lot of folks who
carry that baggage of my eight year old
doesn't want to move and he's in a good
middle school
this is appreciate that this is I feel
like that I'm doing it with their best
interest in mind but they do feel that
way so I feel like I'm being selfish by
now
no your job is to take a longer picture
and at the end of the day a unwell an
unhappy dad and an unhappy mom I don't
care where they are is gonna put more
poison into them than having a fun
street to plan or whatever whatever the
the thing that they're gonna present to
you is but I just know a lot of parents
say hey we're gonna go on an adventure
yeah he's got you with his wife there's
some both of you both of your there
we're gonna go on an adventure and we
tell the kids we're going on an
adventure that's the exact words we use
is we're going we're going on a camping
trip for three years and then we may
just decide to stay yeah but you know if
it's not so stinking permanent in your
head it makes it easier to make the
decision and let's try it all right you
know let's try it if it doesn't work
we'll try something else you know and
it's not I don't like the car I'll get
another car I don't like this location
I'll get another location you've never
tried anything else
your whole lives have been there right
so try something else
it worked out well for me my family have
an adventure you know I I don't see a
downside because I think you can undo it
it'd be some financial pain and some
trouble and jobs and a little bit of
embarrassment or whatever else you might
feel but I I think you try it but you
got it you got to both be on board you
got to both be going and maybe you
talked to her in that sense too that
this is not forever mm-hmm I will make
the agreement that if we go and three
years later we're both miserable or
you're completely miserable we can talk
about coming back
yes your man I like that idea because we
do that with cars we do that with
locations but we also do that with my
job I came here for one job and I'm in
an industry that quite frankly I didn't
really know existed right I got to a new
geographic location and I met some great
folks and I had a set of transferable
skills that moved over but I'm doing
something that I hadn't it was so far
not even on my radar I didn't know it
was a thing right it's not a thing we
the only wanted to do it right but he
may take this supply chain yeah gifted
he's got end up somewhere in Texas or in
Alabama or Nashville and then suddenly
he's using this set of skills for a job
that's a better fit for his family
that's wonderful that he's good at that
he didn't even know exist so go for it
man hit the dude in the mouth and
hopefully he falls down and if he
doesn't then when you wake back up off
the canvas and you can go back to
Pennsylvania hey you say we were in the
ring yep
there you go